SPEAKER: This has been a
rough week for our community.
In light of the horrific
tragedy in Orlando
this weekend, I'm so glad that
we can really come together
today to build bridges within
our community and bridges
that make us stronger as
a whole, so we can support
our youth to grow
up safer than we did
and loving themselves in ways
that we didn't know how to.
I think the shooting
has really reawakened
a fear in a lot of us, and
that fear for our safety
and survival in a world
that wants to harm us.
Maybe this fear has faded over
time as we've gotten older,
and as a society as we've all
finally started to grow up.
With so much greater
visibility in the media
and with hard-won legal
victories like gay marriage,
same-sex parental rights,
employment discrimination
protections, many
of us have begun
to feel almost like society
has started to value us.
Many of us in this
room work at companies
that offer us luxuries
like paid parental leave
for same-sex partners,
pay gender affirmation
surgery for trans people, even
LGBT resource groups that throw
events like this with free happy
hour, which is why I know you
guys are all here.
[LAUGHTER]
But let's remember that
so many of these advances
really benefit the
professional class only,
and there are still so many
LGBTQ people right here
in the Bay that are still
every day harassed at work.
They must fight for basic
health care, housing,
and people who live
in a constant or near
constant threat of violence.
The fear that we're
all feeling this week
is a brutal reminder that
there are people out there who
would do us harm,
who want us to hide,
and hate us for even existing.
This fear has never faded for
many people in our community.
Even here, which is
America's gay mecca,
San Francisco, people
in our community
are still fighting to survive,
to feel safe, to be respected,
and to be seen.
Google's theme for pride this
year is pride for everyone.
And I hope today
this theme really
is a call to action for those
of us with relative privilege,
especially those of
us working in tech,
to show up for those
of us who are still
fighting for basic safety,
for a home, for a voice,
and for a place in our
society and our community.
We chose to highlight Bay
Area LGBTQ youth at this event
because so many of
us, so many of them
are impacted disproportionately
by poverty, violence,
and oppression.
So today let's stand in
solidarity with our queer youth
who know the struggle,
and despite it all,
are still resilient
and brilliant.
Without further ado, I want to
introduce our youth speaker,
because we want, of course,
to not be talking about youth
without inviting and
having a youth voice here.
So this is Pablo Rodriguez.
Pablo?
[APPLAUSE]
You good?
[LAUGH]
PABLO RODRIGUEZ: Awesome.
SPEAKER: So I'll just say
a few words about Pablo.
He's an undocumented,
queer, two-spirit Latino,
a graduate of Mission High
School, where he was president
of their GSA, active in
Latino youth organizing
groups, and the organizer of
his school's annual drag show.
He was recently awarded
the eQuality Scholarship
and the Colin Higgins
Youth Courage Award--
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
SPEAKER: --which is, for those
of you who-- I guess you do
know what this is-- a national
LGBT recognition that's
only awarded to three
youth every year
for their contributions
to the queer movement.
So congratulations.
PABLO RODRIGUEZ: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Pablo is
currently attending CCSF
and leading the Undocuworkforce
program at LYRIC.
And let's welcome Pablo.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PABLO RODRIGUEZ: Thank you.
It's such a pleasure to be here.
I was on my flight
into LA last week,
and it was, like,
with a huge headache
because it was my first
time getting on a plane.
And for most of the people here,
probably wasn't the first time.
But for me it was.
So that was really cool.
Well, before I start
telling my story,
I want to thank the creator
for one more day of sun,
for one more day of moon,
for all of the elements that
are around us right now,
to all of the directions,
to the mother [INAUDIBLE],
the mother [INAUDIBLE],
the woman with many names that
is always taking care of us.
So with that, I want to start
with colonization, murder,
rape.
My name is Pablo Rodriguez.
I'm currently living
in the Mission,
and I'd like to see myself
above-- I don't like
to see myself, but
I feel like I'm
one of the last people
currently living
in the Mission with a skin tone.
I identify as queer,
gay, two-spirit,
which is a recent term
that I'm reclaiming.
I have been living in the Bay,
in San Francisco for I don't
know how many
years, but I've been
here since I was 14 years old.
I am still undocumented.
So I was without my mom for
almost eight or nine years,
I believe, ever since she
left me to come out here.
So there was a big
disconnection between her and I.
So when I came out here and
I came out to her two years
after, the disconnection
was bigger.
So let's pretend that
my connection to her
was like from that
distance from there.
She was standing right there,
I was standing right there.
And every time that I
would sit at the table,
it was like seeing a
stranger that I didn't know,
because the only thing that
I was able to recognize
was her voice.
After I said, Mom,
I'm gay, I was
out of that window literally,
because she kicked me out.
Time after, I finally
came back home
and I took on the
initiative to start actually
getting to know her.
So it was two levels
that I had to deal
with of how to start approaching
her and getting to know her
as a mother, and then
also allowing her
to start getting to know me.
So I started by asking her, so
what is your favorite color?
Because I didn't know what
was her favorite color.
And then dipping into
other conversations
that started
developing with time.
Going to Mission High
was really challenging
for a lot of reasons.
One of them has to
do with language.
I didn't even know
how to say hi.
All of the words that I'm saying
right now, that I'm coming out
my lingua, I didn't know how
to say any of these words.
So I'm like, yay, I know
how to speak English now.
[LAUGHTER]
Which was challenging,
but still was
able to manage to
put on the drag show
in a public school
for everybody.
And everybody was attending,
all of the parents
were coming into the room.
Like--
[TAPPING]
[LAUGHTER]
Like, what is the school doing?
Like, why are teachers
in high heels?
Why are students doing this?
And it's like, because we can.
[LAUGH]
So going to school, again,
was really challenging as well
because the whole
language barrier,
and also because even
within the school,
there is not really a focus
on undocumented queer youths.
Usually you have a lot of
presenters coming and teaching
on how to vote and how to sign
up for all of these things,
and a lot of the programs
and a lot of the services
that they offer, a
lot of the things
require a social
security number.
So you can imagine how awkward
it is sitting in the room
and they're telling you to vote
when you clearly know that you
can't.
So that was one of the
things that I noticed.
Especially Mission High School,
it was like all of us-- well,
I at least knew most of
the undocumented kids
in that high school.
So let's pretend we're,
like, in Mission High
School right now and half
of you are undocumented.
So you have, like, a person
there talking about voting,
and half of their class is like,
uh, looking at each other like,
are we really sitting here?
So that was one of
many things that
happened within the
public system as a whole.
And as I mentioned before, I
experienced homelessness right
after I came out to my mother.
And that left me in a very
risky and tricky situation,
because a lot of
people were telling me,
oh, you should contact a lawyer.
We can do this.
We can do that.
Sort of like suing her.
And I was like, I
don't want to do that,
because that can risk her
being able to continue
working here or even being
allowed to stay here.
So it's like, I don't
want to do that.
So coming out as an
undocuqueer is challenging.
It's hard.
It puts you at this place
where you don't exactly
know where to go.
And a lot of programs,
again, don't exactly
know how to deal with that.
A lot of programs are
more focused on LGBT,
but not exactly LGBT people
of color or undocumented.
So again, it's like the
whole intersectionality thing
that we have to start talking
about what intersectionality
is.
And not just talking,
but actually seeing how
that plays a role in society.
So a lot of places
are like, well,
you know, you can get
housing, you can get that,
but if you have a social.
I didn't.
So I had to, like,
maneuver myself
into a lot of different ways.
And that's how I got
to LYRIC, and that's
how I got to meet my
mentor, [? Ed ?] Martinez.
And you know, I was always
looking for resources.
And that sort of leads me into
the fact that in San Francisco,
I have only been here since I
was 14, and right now, I'm 21.
And it's crazy how the lack of
resources for people like me,
it's like the only place
that is right now working
with undocumented queer
youths of color is LYRIC,
and I'm leading that.
There is no other place or in
the Mission or any other place
around San Francisco that
is working with us youths.
And that's something that
I also have to deal with,
because we talk
about colonization
and we talk about
genocide as something
that happened 500 years
ago, but it's not true.
It still continues to
happen every single day.
And again, we also
talk about how--
I put it on here--
the manifest destiny,
and we talk about segregation.
Manifest destiny is still
happening on the Mission.
Segregation still
continues to happen,
because I have to travel
all the way to Oakland just
to get tested, because
[INAUDIBLE], every single time
that I attend [INAUDIBLE] they
tell me, oh, you came too late.
Can you come earlier,
like 7:00 AM?
And I live all
the way in Balboa,
and I have to travel
[INAUDIBLE] out of my way,
and I can't get there on time.
So segregation still happens.
I have to travel all the
way to the East Bay just
to get HIV and STD testing.
I have to travel all the
way to the East Bay just
to meet my friends,
the ones that
used to live on the Mission.
I have to go all the way to the
East Bay just to go and dance.
I have to go all the
way to the East Bay just
to talk about how radical
my thoughts and ideas are.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
I think this talk
just really touched
on a lot of the
subjects that we're
going to be speaking about
with the rest of the panel,
and all these issues
that are so important.
And so thank you once
again for coming and being
the voice of youth,
even though, you
know, there's countless
people, as you were saying,
that are in need of services
in the city, in the Bay Area.
And that's why today we brought
several youth service providers
to talk a little
bit more about what
we can do for
youth, what's going
on on the front
lines, people who
work on the ground
with youth every day.
And in particular, queer
youth to empower and overcome
a lot of these barriers
that Pablo talked about.
STEPHANIE PERRON:
So I'm Stephanie,
and I run Our Space, which
is a queer and trans youth
center in Hayward.
It's a program of Bay Area
Youth Center and Sunny Hills
Services.
We will be celebrating
year six in August,
which is really exciting.
We serve over 150
young people each year
through different programs.
We started our space
really with the idea
of centering queer
and trans youth who
are impacted by systems
and holding them
at the heart of
everything we do,
and really recognizing them for
their strength and their power,
and holding their needs and
experiences at the center.
What we found when we started
our space six years ago
is that the organizations
that Our Space is a part of
works a lot with foster youth,
so I was a mental health
clinician carrying a caseload,
working with foster youth.
And many of my young people
were queer and trans identified.
And as I started trying to link
them to services in the Bay
Area, they wouldn't link.
They were like, I'm not
going to go to this place
and try to be out about
my foster care status.
And there were a lot of
barriers that they experienced
when they tried to access, like,
LGBTQ services in the East Bay.
And so we really
started Our Space,
holding foster care
youth at the center.
So the way Our Space
plays out right now
is that we have a community
center with, like, sort
of typical community center
programming, like movie night,
queer and trans support circle.
We have an intergenerational
community dinner every month,
which everybody
in this room would
be invited to participate in.
It's a really sweet, sweet
community building event.
So we do things like that.
We have mental health services
for queer and trans youth.
We go out into the community
and do workshops in schools
and with other providers.
And we also do a lot of really
specific work with Alameda
County Foster Care.
So we work with their
child welfare workers
and do trainings for them,
and coaching and consulting.
A lot of county workers think
that they don't have any queer
youth on their caseloads,
or that they've never
worked with a gay youth.
And we all know that that's not
true, because queer and trans
youth are disproportionately
represented in the foster care
system.
So we do a lot of work with
them, and we do a lot of work
with families of queer and trans
youth who are in foster care,
and try to get queer
and trans youth who
are in foster care
out of foster care,
or back to a more
permanent situation.
So that's a very mini
overview of what we do.
We also host East Bay
Youth Pride, which
is going on it's fourth year.
It's on October 22, and there's
are some flyers back there.
It's the only youth pride that
happens in the East Bay that
was started by
young people and is
run every year by young people.
So you can totally volunteer
or come hang out with us
at East Bay Youth Pride.
I'll pass to Kate, who I adore.
KATE CALIMQUIM: Hi.
Kate Calimquim.
Program manager at Castro
Youth Housing Initiative.
It is one of several
programs at Larkin Street.
This program is
geared towards LGBTQ
houseless youth, ages 18 to 24.
I think given with the housing
situation in the Bay Area,
you know, there's a
large need for housing,
especially for young
people who come
from all throughout the
Bay Area, California,
even in the United States,
outside of the country.
They come to San Francisco
thinking, oh, rainbows
and unicorns.
I'm going to find my community.
And they come and face
reality, and it's not so much.
So at Castro Youth, we have
30 beds in hotels and housing
in the Castro
District, which helps
youth begin to build their
communities, and whatnot.
And we have case
management services,
which helps link
folks to mental health
services, educational employment
services, health linkages.
I think we have a lot
of trans young people
who come in and
just kind of want
to work on their gender
affirming surgery.
And so we have a lot
of great partnerships
within the community, such
as the LGBT Center Dimensions
Clinic where we help young
people realize and recognize
their goals for personal growth.
It's a two-year program,
or up until folks are 25.
And with that, folks are
able to save a lot of money.
30% of their income goes
towards "rent," quote, unquote.
And it's really a savings
program, which is really great.
And folks can exit
with a lot of money
to help kind of get their
footing in the door.
I could go on and on, but I
figure I'll pass it along.
SPEAKER: We all do
so much up here.
ZAKIYA HARRIS: Hi, everybody.
My name is Zakiya Harris.
I'm from Oakland, California.
I'm one of the co-founders
of Hack the Hood.
Some of you might
have voted for us.
We actually won the
Google Impact Challenge
about a few years
ago, so thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We are a nonprofit
based in Oakland.
We're currently working
throughout the Bay Area.
We engage in low-income
youth of color
specifically in technology.
Our core offering is
a six-week bootcamp
where we pair young
people one-to-one
with a local small business
and their community,
and they build a website for
a local cleaners, artist,
consultant, mom-and-pop
shop, really
lifting up the voices of those
who are not on Google Maps
and are not currently
discoverable online,
and making sure that
they have an opportunity
to really participate
in the changes that
are happening in the city.
The young people that we
serve are 15 to 23-ish.
Many of them are undocumented,
in the foster care system.
We have young people that
are teen parents facing
a variety of barriers,
in addition to being
part of the LGBTQ community.
We also have a lot of staff
who also identify in that way.
So I think a lot of our model
is very culturally relevant,
and it's also about reflecting
the communities that we serve.
And we really try to do
that through all aspects
of our organization.
I'll pass it on.
ERIK MARTINEZ: Hi, everybody.
Buenas tardes.
My name is Erik Martinez.
I work with San Francisco
Unified School District,
and I oversee support
services for LGBT youth.
It has been in existence
for about 25 years.
We're turning 25 this year.
Oh, what else do I want to say?
Oh my gosh.
Blanking out.
Oh, that's right.
I have to mention this or my
boss will say something to me.
It's the first fully integrated
LGBT support services program
in a school district.
[APPLAUSE]
That happened here
in San Francisco.
I was like, I knew I was
going to forget that.
For San Francisco Unified,
I think this topic
is extremely relevant.
90% of the youth who
attend SF public schools
are students of color.
That should be no surprise then
that the majority, about 90%
of our queer youth are
also students of color.
And really, the
goal of our program
is to create sustainable
support services programs
at each individual school
site where we have activities,
information, and education
for all students,
targeted skill building and
support services for groups
of students.
So for example,
gay-straight alliances,
or what they're called now,
gender and sexuality alliances
are an example of that.
And also making sure
that our schools
have one-on-one
support services.
So making sure we have social
workers and culturally informed
nurses as well.
JOCELYN WONG: All right.
Hi.
I'm J-Wo, an artist and activist
and youth mentor in Oakland.
And I've been doing
mentoring with youth,
primarily youth of color, in
Oakland, previously working
with students trying to
get into college, mostly
first generation
college students.
And as of recently,
helping youth entrepreneurs
developing their
own and realizing
their own economic
sustainability themselves.
SPEAKER: Thanks, everyone.
Let's give the panelists
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So I want to start off,
just maybe someone can
reiterate a definition
of intersectionality.
Because all of you are
working in the context
of intersectionality, and I
know Pablo touched on that.
Does anyone want to
give me just kind
of their definition of what
that means specifically
in the context of this work?
Zakiya, thanks.
ZAKIYA HARRIS: I would like
to offer another analogy.
And this is the way I
think of intersectionality.
We all know about nature, right?
Nature is an ecosystem.
And everything in an
ecosystem is connected.
There is no such thing
as linear thinking
or compartmentalization.
From the very
smallest microorganism
to the largest predator,
there is an interrelationship
and connectedness.
And I believe that every
community, particularly
indigenous communities
throughout the world, that
has always been the
view and the perspective
that we have used
for ages and ages.
And I think that
intersectionality
is like a really cool,
modern PC way of saying that.
But I think we also need
to ground ourselves.
And I loved how you opened
up with the four directions,
because you're
grounding us in nature.
You're grounding us
in that remembrance.
And so I think that we need
to continue that perspective.
So that's what I think of.
I think of all
the connectedness,
that you can't talk
about police brutality
without talking
about immigration,
without talking about
capitalism, without talking
about how it affects
people of color.
We understand the
interrelatedness of them.
And I think most importantly,
we need to design for that.
We need to be thinking
about in our design
so we're not just addressing
one particular symptom.
We're looking at the whole
pie and looking how we can
address it from the ground up.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I think the language that we
use when we have these dialogues
and expanding the language
and the concepts that we use
is really important.
So to kind of integrate
that, can some of you
give some stories of
youth in the ecosystem
that they are living
in and coming out of,
and how the different
factors of their identities
and their environment
really affects the way
that they have access
to the resources
that you all are trying
to give and trying
to connect to youth to?
JOCELYN WONG: All right.
I can talk about a
young man that I've
been working with
for a few years
now from when he
started in high school.
A gay young Latino.
And in terms of,
like, issues that
were facing him from this
intersectional point,
he was living in
deep East Oakland,
attending Castlemont, which if
you know Oakland is like out
on 90 or something.
You know, it's a tougher school.
There's definitely some
incidents of violence
that happened there.
He lives in a neighborhood where
shootings, drive-bys, domestic
abuse, they exist there.
His parents are also--
they're both immigrants.
They don't speak English.
Neither of them had
attended college.
I think only one of his parents
had finished high school,
or equivalent to that.
So when he was thinking
about attending college,
the issues of his
sexuality, being Latino--
you know, so he was
in a lot of hiding.
And then trying to access
resources that he didn't know,
his family didn't really know.
So he was coming-- he
was speaking with me
as like kind of a confidant
in terms of his sexuality,
but then he really needed
to access resources and help
for continuing his
education, finding financing
for that, which was actually
probably one of the harder
barriers for him,
and doing all of that
within his geographic place that
was violent and under-resourced
overall.
So it's not like he had
just one of these barriers
to face or to
overcome or deal with,
but there were multiple layers
that he had to deal with.
And I think actually,
his parents still
don't know about his sexuality.
He's still in the
closet with them,
and he still lives with them
out of financial need and such.
So three years down the road,
he's actually still facing
a number of these
challenges based on,
you know, the class,
the immigration status
of his parents, his race,
his sexuality altogether.
KATE CALIMQUIM: You
know, sitting up here
thinking about the young
people that I've worked with,
I guess a good
general example I have
is working with multiracial
young people who initially
came out as lesbian
or gay, and yet
as they explore their
identity, begin to transition
to another gender.
And so trying to work
with either-- so with that
as a transition from
male to female, you know,
the loss of access and privilege
as a male-bodied person,
working with internalized
racism from their families
and communities of origin,
and how that all plays out
with this young person
who also came up
with some class privilege.
And so as they come
to San Francisco
and begin to get involved with
just kind of homeless youth
organizations and just kind of
that loss of privilege, being
able to begin working with
community organizations really
focused on racial identity
and working through,
how do they navigate
those systems?
So there's a lot of
processing to be done.
And how do we build
folks' self-identities
in the face of so many of
challenging situations.
Coming up without privilege.
You know, just kind of
coming in, recognizing
how they lose
privilege in a sense,
and also coming
to-- yeah, sorry.
STEPHANIE PERRON:
No, that was good.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
KATE CALIMQUIM: Yeah.
STEPHANIE PERRON: I'm
thinking about a young person
I've had the honor and
privilege of working
with since she was 14.
She's 19 now, and
she came to Our Space
when she was 14 because
she lived in a group home
the other agency runs.
And after about a month
of coming to Our Space,
she came out as a trans girl,
which was really exciting,
and she was really
affirmed for her identity.
But when you're in
the foster care system
as like-- I mean, when you're in
the foster care system period,
and then when you're
in the foster care
system as, like, a
queer or trans person,
and then you're
in the foster care
system as, like, a
trans girl of color--
she identifies as black-- she
had a really rough time of it.
Then she was bounced around
from different placements
and placements and placements.
And I think that one of
the things that happens
is that a lot of providers
in the foster care system
are white, look like me,
or a lot of white women,
and we bring our own frames
to the situation, right?
And so I think it's really
easy for young people
in the foster care system,
especially when they're
queer and trans youth of
color, to get read as violent,
to get read as aggressive, to
get read as they don't care
about school, to get read
as all these awful things.
But what's really going on is
that they're getting harassed
in their placements
all the time,
and their safety is in
jeopardy all the time.
So like leaving a foster
care placement is actually,
like, a really amazing
act of survival, to leave.
So this young person's been in
foster care since they were 14.
There's a law in
California that's
called the AB 12 that extended
foster care to the age of 21.
So 18 to 21-year-olds are
allowed to be in foster care.
Which is actually kind
of an awesome thing,
because you're supposed to
be able to have housing when
you're in foster care,
and you have access
to a lot more resources.
This young person,
whom I love so much,
has bounced around a lot, and
had, like, my phone number
written on her backpack.
So she would work
the streets a lot
and sort of get trafficked from
Oakland to LA and back again.
So she was gone a
lot of the time.
And she's one of
those young people,
as I'm sure that we all have
these young people in our lives
who we're always like,
I hope you're alive.
Like, I want you to be alive.
But they don't know if you're
alive or if you're not.
And then you get the phone
call every few months,
and you hear their voice.
So one year ago, she
showed up at my office,
and it was like 5:30
at night, or something.
The end of the day.
And she looked rough.
Like, she looked
not in good shape.
And she had literally
just gotten back from LA.
I hadn't seen her
in over a year,
heard from her in over a year.
And she was 19 at this point.
So still legally supposed to
be able to be in foster care,
right?
Like, you all are
with me on this.
So I say, let's get you food.
You're here.
Let's do this.
I'm going to call your
county worker right now.
We're going to
find you placement.
Her foster care case
was in the county that's
outside of Alameda County.
So for me as a provider, I
don't hold the relationship
with those other
providers as well.
So we get the county
worker on the phone,
and they can do nothing.
They say, oh, you're
a non-minor dependent.
You're 19.
You're not in work
or school right now,
so you don't meet
the requirements,
which is actually
not true, y'all.
She didn't have to
be in work or school.
But there was nowhere to go.
And then I spent two or
three hours on the phone,
trying to find housing
for this young person.
And I can echo, like, the
Bay Area housing crisis.
In the East Bay, there
are very limited options
in terms of shelters, and
the main youth shelter
had a wait list
that was 43 deep.
Other shelters that we may
have been able to get her into
were mostly men's
shelters, where
it wasn't necessarily
going to be safe for her
as a trans girl.
So what we end up doing after
all this time is that I coach
her, which I just want to name.
This is, like, probably one
of the low, lowest moments
of my professional
career, but I coach her
into what to say to get her a
bed at John George Psychiatric
Hospital so that she can have
a safe bed for the night.
Because she doesn't want to,
like, ride the bus all night.
Like, we can't figure out
anywhere where she can go.
And if anybody's ever
had an experience
with an adult
psychiatric hospital,
they're not necessarily safe
places for the queer and trans
community.
So anyway, I say all this just
that she has a lot going on
in her life, right?
And with a team of lawyers that
we were able to connect her
with and with lots
of other supports,
it has still been, like,
an infinite struggle
to get her back enrolled
in the foster care system.
And so I mean, she's
currently in prison right now.
But I think about
this a lot, right?
I think a lot about if she was
a white, straight, cisgender
young person who
acted a certain way
and talked a certain
way to county workers,
would her trajectory be
much different than what
it is right now?
And I think when she gets out,
she could in theory have access
to post-foster care housing.
But she doesn't have a family.
She doesn't have, like,
emotional, connected support,
community in her life.
She doesn't have
anybody supporting her
with real job skills and job
training and things like that.
So just to think about what's
going on for this young person
and intersectionality.
I think also really
quickly, I'll
just say that the life
expectancy of a black trans
woman in our country
is 35 years old.
And so I mean, we should
say it again, right?
The life expectancy of a black
trans woman in our community
is 35 years old.
And so we need to hold that.
SPEAKER: Thanks so much
for sharing that story
and for the other
stories that were shared.
I think part of why
I invited everyone
that is doing this
on the ground work
is to show what is happening
in our communities,
in our LGBTQ community,
and to really
get us motivated to understand
where people are coming from,
and to act on that and get
involved in any way we can.
I think it's
important to know how
all these different factors,
different aspects of identities
combine to limit
access to resources.
And even though we're all
here coming from resources
that are funded,
they're set up, they're
supposed to be giving care and
giving services and getting
youth, getting kids,
teenagers, children
out of these situations
that you're describing,
there are so many
factors that have
to do with the racial
identity and queer
identity and oppression that
intersect to limit access
to those resources that are
supposed to be helping them.
I was going to ask
about, what are
some typical misconceptions
about the youth that you all
serve?
And I think Stephanie, you
just touched on a lot of those.
Why can't people-- if there
are services like foster
care all the way until
21, why aren't they in it?
Does anyone else want to
speak to misconceptions
about the youth
that they work with?
And also maybe some
innovative ways
that they've identified their
needs and met their needs
in the face of all
of these barriers.
ZAKIYA HARRIS: Well, I've
worked with young people
my whole career, over 13 years.
And I've worked in a
variety of settings
as a classroom teacher,
after-school programs.
And I think one
misconception that I always
hear, particularly in
workforce development, which
is the work I'm doing now, is
a surprise at the brilliance
of young people of color.
Oh my God, they're so smart.
Oh, they really get it.
They really know how to code.
They really want to be better.
They're great leaders.
And then this thinking of,
like, we're making them leaders,
or we're imbuing
them with something.
And I think that our young
people are so resilient.
Young people are so
freaking resilient.
And I feel like all
the young people
I've had the
opportunity to work with
have overcome tremendous
barriers every day
just getting up in the morning
to make it to the program,
to your point.
You know, all the
hurdles that most adults
would have failed at hurdle
number one, literally.
And they get no credit for that.
And the expectation
is just like, oh well.
And I think that a lot of
work gets put into the tools,
whether we want to train
them to do this or train
them to do that.
But we don't talk
about the trauma.
We don't talk about the
21st century skills.
We spend a lot of
time at Hack the Hood
talking about the future of
work and the new set of tool box
that every young
person has to have now.
And the fact that all of the
rules that apply to everyone
in this room are dead.
They don't apply anymore.
What it takes for a young
person to navigate childhood
into any type of
career trajectory
is completely nuanced now.
It has to do with your
social network, who you know.
navigational capital,
your ability to see where you
want to go and to understand
what it means to get there.
You have to be able to speak.
You have to be able
to code switch.
There's so many other things
that you have to be able to do,
and it's not just
the technical skill.
And I think a lot
of times we just
focus on this technical thing
that a young person's supposed
to know, like we got to
where we are because of just
the technical skill, right?
Like, we all navigated
something new.
But when we're talking about
communities, because we're
othering these communities
as someone else,
we want to put a new
set of rules on them.
And those rules just
don't fit anymore.
So I think that we
have to-- again,
I think it's a design
challenge, right?
We have to start designing
differently, thinking
differently, and really
starting with the assets
of our young people.
And so at Hack the
Hood, we do as strengths
finder assessment-- you
guys probably did that--
with all of our young people.
And we have found it to be,
like, it just kind of makes
everyone's back stand
taller when they recognize
the fact that they
have gifts, they
were born with strengths that
are something that they love
and something that
they're good at.
And we really focus
on that and think
about technology as a
tool that they can use
to kind of harness that work.
So we're not kind
of putting them
on a track towards anything.
We're allowing them to
really harness their gifts,
and we don't limit the
conversation around technology
to a few companies like
Google and Facebook.
You know, there is
no career trajectory
that any of our young
people are going
to go into where technology
is not at the center of that.
We don't think about being
an entrepreneur as something
that you have to become.
Everybody's an entrepreneur
in the 21st century.
It doesn't matter if you've
got a main job, a side
hustle, a passion project.
You're not just going
to have one job.
You're probably
going to have three.
So how do we prepare
young people?
And then when we start adding
all the barriers, oh my God.
Now you've got the low
income, the youth of color,
the queer, the
homeless, the mom.
All those other barriers
get stacked on top of that.
And then when we
talk about housing
and we talk about
homeless, when we
look at some of the homeless
folks on the streets,
we're working with
their youth, you know?
That's another level
of trauma of seeing
Auntie sleeping in a tent.
And so just not recognizing
all of those connections
in that young people are kind
of surviving against all odds.
So you know, I'm just
proud of all of our youth.
I think that young
people really get it.
They have the answers.
They don't need anybody
kind of telling them.
We really need to listen more.
We need to be quiet and
let the youth speak,
and really just kind of
use them as our teachers,
because they have so much vision
and inspiration to guide us in.
And I think that's part of what
it means to just really honor
youth where they're at, and
also kind of start debunking
those misconceptions.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
JOCELYN WONG: Yeah, I
super agree with all that.
I think a common
misconception that I've
seen a lot of young people deal
with is that they don't know
what's best for them,
that they're young,
they don't know the
real world, or they
don't know, like, what's
in their own best interest.
But that's usually
many times coming
from people that aren't
facing the same problems
and struggles that those
young people are facing.
So if anybody knows the
problems that they're facing
and how to deal
with those problems,
it's those young people
that are dealing with them.
They're growing up
in a world or they've
been living in a world
that didn't exist before.
And you know, thinking
about how maybe we grew up,
we didn't have the technologies
and the things that were
going on that's happening now.
And so they're facing
problems that some of them
are new problems,
and some of them
are systemic problems
that have always existed.
But they definitely know.
Like, they want the
best for themselves.
It's not like they
don't want the best
possible life they could get.
But you see a lot of times,
people with money, affluence,
privilege coming in
and saying, well,
we know the best way for you
to be economically empowered.
And so you follow this
path that we followed,
and you'll be in the
same place as us.
When it's like, they're
starting from a whole
different-- they're
on a different island
in another country.
Like, it's a totally
different trajectory
that they're going
to have to follow.
And so if anything, if
you maybe provide access
to resources or
access to knowledge,
they can solve the
problems for themselves.
Like, we're not trying to
solve problems for them.
We just want to maybe give
them tools or tips or skills
so that they can solve
their own problems.
Because chances
are, I have no idea
what the problem they're
facing is to begin with.
I might conceptually understand
a problem they're faced with,
but they have the experience
of what this problem is
and how to solve it in
the best way for them
and their community.
ERIK MARTINEZ: Yeah, I kind of
want to add to what both of you
were saying.
You know, queer youth
of color are fierce.
[LAUGHTER]
They are strong.
You know, I think back to just
some of those early documented
experiences on film.
You know, "Paris Is Burning"
is a great example of how
communities can create their
own communities of resilience
and cultural capital
and social capital,
even when facing multiple
points of marginalization.
I think one of the unique
things about, I think,
and where I sit in
the school district
is I get to see kids at
multiple ages, right?
I get to see them in
elementary school,
I get to see them
in middle and high.
And currently,
I'm in the process
of hiring some staff
for some of our schools,
that I'm seeing graduates
return after college who want
to work with their schools.
And one thing I'm
noticing is how
experiences of
marginalization also
affect the way they
show up, because they
have to work twice as hard to be
perceived to be strong, right?
It's not about whether or
not they're strong or not.
It is about perception.
And to me, just looking
at queer candidates,
our white queer
candidates are coming in
with that sense of entitlement,
that sense of, I am capable.
I can do this, and be able to
sell themselves really well.
Whereas a lot of our
candidates of color,
they're groomed to
think that they're
lucky to be given the little
bits and pieces that they're
given, right?
So how they come off in a job
interview can be very, very
different, even though on
paper they are just as amazing,
they are just as strong.
So I think about Pablo
and my first meeting
with him, when I first met
Pablo, he was at Mission.
He was a sophomore-- freshman.
I mean, this kid was fierce.
I was like, why am I
coming into this school?
[LAUGH]
It looks like he
has it going on.
But it was really a matter
of, how do I as a queer adult,
as a person who has
achieved privilege,
but also understands the
path that he's going through,
to mentor him to not
just find his strength,
but believe in his strength?
Because it's already there.
He just needs to see it, and
they just need to believe it.
So I think when we think
about queer youth of color
in particular is that
they have the answers,
they have the power, and it's
our responsibility as adults
to help them realize that.
To show a mirror
and be like, no.
You got it.
Don't believe this other BS.
Like, you have it
and you can do it.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Yeah.
Applause.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGH]
On that note, I
guess, what do you
see-- where do you see queer
leadership and queer youth
leadership taking place?
And what form is that
taking with the youth
that you're working with?
We talk a lot about the
barriers that they're facing,
but how are they surpassing our
expectations in terms of taking
on their own leadership?
ZAKIYA HARRIS: Well, I
think that, again, we
need to ground ourselves
in the reality.
The March on Washington was
organized by a queer man.
You can Google a great speech
by Huey P. Newton, founder
of the Black Panther
Party, talking
about how the black
nationalist movement needs
to work with queers as
allies and hold them close.
The entire Black
Lives Matters movement
was created and catalyzed
by black queer women.
They've changed the
entire national narrative,
and arguably the
global narrative,
pushing not just black rights,
but rights for everybody
into the forefront.
So again, we've
always been here.
We've always been pushing.
I think now with
technology, and there's
kind of a different lens
and a different way,
you know, we're
using these stories.
But I think that we just need
to recognize that we're still
standing on the shoulders
of great leaders,
and continuing
that conversation.
And oftentimes,
that conversation
just hasn't been heard.
It's like, police brutality,
it was always going on.
We just didn't have it on tape.
So it's like the same thing
with the queer rights movement.
It's always been there.
And now because of technology
and because there's
a spotlight, some
of those stories
get to percolate up further.
KATE CALIMQUIM: I
think kind of speaking
towards that, I
think as our nation,
as we become more diverse,
as awareness is raised
towards gender and sexual
orientation, all those things,
I see just the
millennials growing up
and moving into those
leadership positions.
I think as we
become more diverse,
our young people
are leading the way.
They're doing the
work that they need
to do on that ground
level, and easily
see in a few decades from
that-- or a few years
from now doing really well.
ZAKIYA HARRIS: If I
could add, I mean, I
think the work needs to happen
from the other folks that
aren't in the queer community.
I don't think the
onus is on, what
is the queer community doing?
It's more like, how can other
people be allies and support
the work of the queer community?
And there was a
great quote or tweet
that was going around
after the Orlando massacre
that I read that said, dear
heterosexual black man,
will you stand for us
the way we stood for you?
From a gay black man.
And so that's a question.
Will everyone else
stand up the way
that they have been standing
up on the front lines for us?
SPEAKER: Thank you.
On that note, what would you say
allyship and advocacy actually
looks like for coming from
queer people of privilege,
relative privilege, white,
cisgender, male, affluent,
able-bodied people?
And how can we redefine help
to be defined by the people who
are needing that?
ERIK MARTINEZ: One of
my favorite definitions
of allyship and
thinking about the fact
that this work
has been happening
for some time, a
really great ally
is someone who takes the
hit, but not the credit.
So someone who can
use their privilege
to really shield and
protect and move forward
without claiming that
somehow they made it up,
or they're bringing
this to light.
And that happens
all the time, and I
think allies need to really
check their egos in this work.
Is it really about
the communities
that you're working
with, or is it about you
needing to be seen as a savior?
And I think that's
a real conversation
and reflection that a lot
of our allies need to have.
STEPHANIE PERRON: I
really agree with that.
And I think just
thinking tangibly
about if I'm thinking
about queer and trans
youth I'm working
with right now,
I'm thinking about something
that somebody said earlier
about letting young people lead.
So I'm thinking about having
money available to young people
to make their dreams
come true that
doesn't have any
strings attached to it,
or doesn't have to be,
like, evidence-based
or something like that, right?
Like, are we supporting
communities and coming up
and doing what they
know already works?
And so how are we
funding that situation?
I think also
tangibly, I can't help
but think about housing
and just all the queer
and trans young folk that
we've probably all seen
that just don't have housing.
There's the host housing program
that happens in Minnesota
that I've always been dreaming
of learning more about,
where folks in the community
are housing folks for queer
and trans.
Even where queer and trans youth
get to interview them and like
decide if they're safe enough
for them to go stay with.
But I wonder about
getting really
creative about housing
strategies in the Bay Area,
and how we could all
really work together
to form a network of support
for our young people.
Because the reality
is that there's not
the funding or the
institutional support.
Like, it's not going to happen
just through one program
because the need is
so great right now.
Those are some tangible
things I'm thinking about.
KATE CALIMQUIM: Some--
[LAUGHTER]
Something I find, I
think as we are all here,
I think we're in a sense
maybe speaking to the choir.
I think we like to think that
we're aware, we're conscious.
And I think I want to
challenge folks to bring that
back to your families,
your friends who may not
be so supportive or aware.
Have those really tough
conversations over family meals
and family reunions
where auntie or uncle may
be spouting something
where it's just like, no,
that's not right.
I think those are ways
folks can show up.
Because we can't have those
conversations because they
don't care about us.
But if they're talking to
you who they adore greatly,
that has more
resonance, and I think
can help really allow
folks to critically think
about the issues.
SPEAKER: So I think after
the event also, we're
going to pass out some
information to all
the attendees about
kind of concrete ways
that people can contribute
and get involved,
but is there anything
else anyone would
like to say in terms of, what
are things we can do right
now, today, in terms of
donation, volunteering,
mentorship that your
organizations might be needing?
ZAKIYA HARRIS:
Well, we love money.
[LAUGHTER]
But that's not all you can do.
That's not all you can do.
I think that particularly
around the whole digital tech
inclusion conversation,
one thing that's
been really apparent
for my work at Hack
the Hood is that
we love the checks.
However, if y'all not hiring--
so when we talk about those
pathways and on-ramps,
you know, is that real?
Because the check is
only going to go so far.
And think about
the personal trauma
and how debilitating that
is for our young people who
are working so hard to get
something, and then to find,
again, all that 21st century
skills stuff starts popping up,
because the technical
is not enough.
I think on a personal
level, everybody
needs to do some serious
anti-oppression work, you know?
And not just the people who are
coming to train you at Google.
You know, your
own personal work.
Privilege is transitory.
We all have it.
We navigate it constantly.
So really focusing on your
own personal privilege
and how that shows up,
again, holistically,
in all aspects of your life
from the housing decisions
that you're making to the
neighborhoods that you live in.
I think we need to
vote with our dollars.
Every time you're
spending money,
you're making a
conscious decision
to support the new world
that we want to create
or an old system that we
see the havoc that it's
wreaking on the world.
And I think starting
with your own community,
you know, I think what
has been echoed here,
I think the tendency
is always to go
outside of your community.
Well, we've got experts
in our community.
We really need you
being on the front lines
of your own community,
spreading this gospel,
pushing the narrative, pushing
your peers, your family
members, having those
uncomfortable conversations,
not needing to tokenize
the folks of color
or the queer people in the room
to bring up the folk of color,
queer people conversations
in the meeting.
How can you be an ally if you
don't identify with that way
to stick up for those
folks, and really
make sure those
conversations are being had?
So I think we have
to kind of start
small as well,
and kind of really
looking at what we
can do at all times.
Even myself, I'm always
having to confront
that conversation
as well as someone
that is an American citizen.
I had to do a lot of work
on expanding my own lens
about undocumented youth not
just being limited to Latinos,
to have to really be allies to
my African brothers and sisters
and my West Indian brothers
and sisters who are
part of the African diaspora.
And like, wow.
I didn't even think about you in
the undocumented conversation,
and knowing that I have
people in my own community
that were facing those
barriers, you know?
So how can I be
more of an advocate
when immigration in these
conversations come up?
And not just thinking, oh,
that doesn't include me,
or that doesn't
include my people,
because it actually does.
JOCELYN WONG: I think
just bouncing off
that, I think-- yeah,
you can write a check,
and maybe even hire people.
But there's the problem of
getting them to stay as well.
And so I've worked
with two young people
in particular that
I'm thinking of that
did go through work development,
job skills training.
They got jobs.
And a couple months
into it, they're
just like, I don't want to
work for this white lady.
Like, I can't really
deal with this.
Like, there's all these
microaggressions, and over
and over, and they're out.
I mean, they did all the steps
that they were shown to follow,
and they got the job.
Like, they were there.
They made it, or whatever.
But then the cultures that
all these different privileges
and biases that we have that
have been ingrained in us
since day one, they're
still going to show up.
Even if I hire the
person of color,
I hire the young
but then I make it
kind of uncomfortable
for them to stay there, how
good is that on its own?
Like, you did kind
of part of the job,
but it's actually incomplete
because they're leaving shortly
after they're getting there.
I just wanted to
say that [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Anyone else?
I think there's so
much valuable stuff
to say about this topic and
about economic empowerment
for the youth that
are really struggling,
getting them there,
keeping them there, getting
all the benefits that
come for queer people,
working within
professional organizations,
professional companies as I
mentioned at the beginning.
So let's do it.
I think with that, I want to
open it up to the audience
to ask questions.
And if you can just stand
up and shout out something,
and I'll repeat it
so everyone can hear.
[LAUGHTER]
Just to repeat so everyone
can hear, but yeah.
How do the people who
are being oppressed
have to not be the ones to
educate others about how
not to oppress them, right?
I learned.
[LAUGHTER]
ZAKIYA HARRIS: Well, we have a
module at Hack the Hood that's
called code switching.
And we really frame code
switching as something
that you're not trying
to be someone else
and really rooting
that, but you understand
that there are ways that we
have to show up sometimes
in different rooms.
And it doesn't
mean that you don't
get to be your authentic self,
but you are aware of that.
And sometimes our
young people don't even
understand that that's even
anything, that they are even
aware of that.
So I think empowering young
people with that language.
We also introduced the
concept of microaggressions.
We want them to
understand that language,
to have vocabulary to understand
that they have their own power
to navigate.
And it was one of the most
difficult modules to create,
and I did a lot of
work writing it,
because there was no
solution at the end.
It wasn't like, OK.
I'm going to teach
you how to do this,
and then everything's
going to be OK.
It's like, you know what?
I'm going to give you some
language and some tools,
and I really hope that
you can use these in life.
And I think that that really
speaks to that 21st century
tool box that I talked
about where we're empowering
young people with a
set of tools that they
can use to navigate
and architect
and build a life that
they want to live.
And that they have
the self-confidence
to give that pushback
in a corporate setting
to a supervisor, to
speak their truth,
to understand how
they can navigate,
to have a support system, and
to start addressing these things
and understanding
that there's also
some systematic things at
play that we haven't really
talked about.
We've done a lot of talk
today about individuals
and organizations,
but there's also
this whole system
we're part of called
the United States of America
that's a capitalist system.
And so, you know, how
are we also bringing that
in as well to the conversation?
Even from something
as simple as what
it means to be an entrepreneur,
and reframing what that means.
And so just making
money isn't sufficient.
If you're not
thinking about people,
if you're not thinking
about the planet--
so we don't have to
just limit businesses
to capitalist endeavors.
So you know, it's a whole
kind of context, I think,
that we really have
to work to build.
And for young people to see
themselves as part of that
and to understand
that your job doesn't
define who you
are-- something else
we do is we create a life title.
Every young person creates
a life title for themselves.
Not a job title, a life title.
So your job title
will come and go.
Some people don't
have a job, so they
might feel like they don't have
any-- what is their purpose?
And so young people use the
strength finder activity
to actually create a life
title, like, I'm a solutionary,
I'm a pathfinder, I'm
a strategic cultivator.
So they understand
that your worth is not
defined by your job and
who's bigging you up,
that you're part of
something bigger than this,
and that this job is one
part of a very long journey
that you're going to be on.
So again, it still comes back
to the confidence building,
and how can we really
work to address
the trauma that really keeps us
from being our greatest selves?
SPEAKER: So in light
of all the negativity
that we've been
feeling this week,
in light of the incident
over the weekend in Orlando,
what are some positive takeaways
about the impact that you're
making in your organizations
and how we're really reaching
people and making change?
STEPHANIE PERRON: So there's--
I'm not going to remember
the website right now, but
I'm going to get it to you.
[LAUGHTER]
I will get it to you.
But we had the
honor and privilege,
seven queer and
transing people who
come to Our Space made these
really dope digital stories
about the impact of mental
health on their life.
So they're not always, like,
the easiest stories to watch.
But it's kind of
amazing that there's
this really cool free
curriculum thing out there.
So I think that's one
cool thing that we're
doing, is we're trying
to change the narrative
around mental
health particularly,
holding queer and trans
youth of color at the center.
And so it's really cool,
and it's really cute.
And there's a flyer
back there with pictures
of the young people on it.
It's really cute.
KATE CALIMQUIM: So one question
that I meant to answer earlier
was just kind of what I
would want you to know
about the population we serve.
The thing with homeless
youth in San Francisco,
any one of y'all, any of the
youth that I work with can be
amongst y'all, and y'all
wouldn't even know.
So I mean, I think there's
this kind of stereotype
of what a homeless person looks
like, a homeless youth looks
like.
And I mean, I think the
youth that I've worked with,
they've gone to Stanford,
they've worked at eBay.
So I mean, it's just
one of those things
where homelessness
can happen to anyone.
And our youth in
general, given the fact
that 40% of all
homeless youth are
LGBT, that says a lot in
terms of the experiences
they have of rejection
and exclusion.
Couple that with challenges in
the educational system where
youth are bullied and
the fact that, I believe,
30 some odd states don't
have nondiscrimination laws
for LGBT people.
You know, I think with all
those kind of challenges,
being able to be
in a space watching
young people grow for two
years, kind of blossom
into themselves.
One of my favorite
stories is a young person
who came into services, and very
beginning of their transition.
Very isolated, very
disconnected from their family,
a lot of mental
health challenges.
And through our work together,
really blossomed into her own.
Finding her community, being
able to fully transition,
and be on the path.
Getting education
down, employment,
you know, stably
employed for one year.
A lot can happen in two years.
And so I think with the right
support, the right mentors,
the right kind of folks
pushing or encouraging folks,
pushing for success, I think
that can make a huge impact.
If I may add one
more story, I think
another aspect is-- there
was a quote that someone
had mentioned where like
trans-- and this one,
was it related to trans youth?
It was like,
trans-affirming services
can be a form of
suicide prevention.
And so looking at how we can
be culturally competent, how
we can be strong
allies, that can
be the solution to help kind
of ease things for folks.
ERIK MARTINEZ: Yeah, I think
for me, a little bit of conflict
with this question
just because I
was raised by two
Mexican-Catholic parents.
So humility.
It's all about humility.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'll try a little bit.
So I think for me, I think
one of the daunting tasks
was being an LGBT programs
coordinator in a system
of about 60,000 kids.
So what does impact mean?
What does it mean
to change a system?
And I think I arrived
at a point where I was
like, I can't do it all alone.
I have to work with community.
So over the past two and a half
years, it's been really about,
how can I not just work
with kids individually,
get them access to
services, but then
also make sure my community
is on board to support me
in this work?
In this last year, I was really
lucky to implement a program
where we provide
confidential LGBT support
groups across
multiple high schools
where students who identify
can come in without stigma
and seek mentorship and
information from other queer
adults like them.
And not just any queer adults,
but also queer adults of color.
So in creating that program and
kind of in advocating for it,
I was unapologetic in
my ask to my colleagues,
to our program
directors of, like,
if we're going to
do this right, we
need to have clear
POC staff on board.
And it was challenging,
but we made it happen.
And this year, which
is our first full year
of implementation, we had
contact with about 75 queer POC
kids in our school
district, which
to me is an accomplishment.
Because in the past, I think we
over-relied on extracurricular
clubs to catch kids.
And what we found was there
were some kids in there,
and we had a lot of
enthusiastic allies.
A lot of girls, which is great.
But that's not always
the means in which
we can work with our kids
directly and go deeper.
So I think the school
system has seen the need,
and I think have seen the
positive relationships that we
can have across generations.
And so continue
to push for that,
and continue to push for
community to be involved,
and to infiltrate our
systems is very important.
And I also want to
give a shout out.
There's an audience member,
Dar Garcia over there,
who was one of my
infiltrators as well.
[LAUGHTER]
PABLO RODRIGUEZ: So I'm kind
of feeling a little weird
about that question.
Sorry.
But-- well, actually not sorry.
I feel a little weird,
because every time
we talk about a lot of the
things that we were talking
might seem negative.
But I actually don't
see them as negative.
I actually see them
as constructive.
So it really depends out to
you how you want to take that.
I see that very constructively,
all of the stories and things
that we're currently sharing.
And even if it's
negative, I feel
like society has created
this social amnesia where
we want to not really see that.
We want to, like, pretend
that it's not there.
And because we're talking about
it, it's opening that wound.
All of the things that
we're currently doing
is, like, creating
a small Band-Aid
on the bigger social challenges
that are currently happening.
So if you ever
feel a trigger, you
feel like a wound is
currently opened, it's OK.
You know, it's OK if you
feel any type of feeling,
if you think it's too negative.
It's fine.
It's totally fine.
The positive is I'm embracing
right now that I'm alive.
Just the fact that a
queer person of color
is alive today, that's
a positive, actually.
And just think about that.
Just think about how the fact
that a queer person of color
is just breathing is
actually a positive thing.
Because we were supposed to
be dead from colonization
500 years ago.
500 years ago, my
two-spirit people
were supposed to be
completely exterminated,
but I'm still here.
So the fact that I'm here,
it's like a positive.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: So for all of
you that are working
on the ground with youth,
you have so much to give
and so much to offer,
but what is the one thing
that you would hope
that youth take away
after having some contact
with you through your work?
ERIK MARTINEZ: I'll
keep it really short.
A moment of relief.
I think being able to talk to
someone and maybe be authentic,
and even in a second, can
be a life-saving moment,
can bring at least
a moment of hope
or at least plant that seed.
So to me, relief stands out.
STEPHANIE PERRON: I
think fierce love,
that they know that
they're fiercely loved,
that they don't ever
have to silo off
any piece of their identity
to show up and be with us.
ZAKIYA HARRIS: I would
just want them to remember
that they have the power.
You have the power,
is what I would
want them to be able to
hold in times of difficulty.
That everything that
they need is within them.
KATE CALIMQUIM: During
challenging bits,
I tell folks, hey, we got you.
Now let's get some work done.
JOCELYN WONG: Oh, was that me?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOCELYN WONG: Oh.
This better?
Yeah.
I really like
Zakiya's statement.
I guess with the youth
that I'm working with,
I want them to know that they're
their own answer for things,
for whatever it is.
Like, they can be the
best solution for whatever
it is that they're facing.
PABLO RODRIGUEZ: So I also
work with youth, actually,
which is fun to do
because I'm also youth.
[LAUGHTER]
And we actually
did this activity
before too where [INAUDIBLE]
we went around with, like,
which was the word
that came to their mind
when they first saw me?
And they were like,
the colonization.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm like, yay.
So the colonization.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Real talk.
Any final questions?
So I think the question is,
how can companies like Google
and other tech
companies represent
the stories and the
identities of the people
who need that represented and
need to see more of themselves
within those spheres?
ZAKIYA HARRIS: I think there are
two things that came to mind.
I think folks gotta work harder.
I think that-- and we love
Google, and I love Google--
but I think we have to go
beyond just a Google search.
I think that their
stories are out there,
but you have to work a
lot harder to find them.
And I think that even with
hiring, that's always the MO.
We don't know anybody.
You know, and it's
always like-- I
feel like white privilege
always gets to say that.
We can't find enough people.
We don't know anybody.
We couldn't see the thing.
And it's like,
people of color never
have that privilege of
saying they don't know.
Go to a job and tell
your boss you don't know,
they'll find someone
else to do the job.
But white privilege always
gets to say they don't know.
And so I think the
stories are out there.
There's tons of
stories out there.
So how can companies
like Google work harder
to maybe move beyond just
the people that are trending
or the stories that
we get bombarded with?
Like you were saying that you
were reading all these stories
about Orlando.
We get these dominant
messages that
are made the program of the
week until the new conversation,
the new traumatic thing.
And we can't just focus
on that narrative.
We have to seek
other narratives.
We have to seek other
sources of information.
We have to seek
other communities.
Like, we're all local.
We're all in your community.
How many of you
guys knew about us
before walking into this room?
And it's great that
this is a platform,
but we can't just
become so complacent
that we only give an
ear to what's easy
and what's easy to find.
And so I think folks just have
to work a little bit harder
to lift up those stories and
to understand that sometimes
they're not going
to be as polished
and not going to be as
savvy, and maybe you're
using a different language.
Maybe you're speaking
with a different kind
of dialect and tone.
They might dress
differently, hairstyles
might look-- we have to open
ourselves up to gaining wisdom
from people who maybe
don't personify, you know,
a cis white male
of what you know,
what a construction
of power looks like.
We have to kind of start
unpacking that a little bit.
So that's one thing.
[APPLAUSE]
JOCELYN WONG: Yeah,
on that too, I
think it might be
less in terms of,
what algorithm can we write so
that different news stories can
come up?
But I think a lot of
it is from internal.
Because if you have a very
specific demographic that's
running the show,
thinking about how
they can change to address
this other demographic,
you might as well just
get the other demographic
to figure out how a company
could be run or function that
would address them.
Because, you know,
if you're going
to have maybe like a straight,
white cis male that's
really affluent,
trying to figure out
what we can do to help maybe
a queer person of color,
it's probably best to just ask
the queer person the color.
Hire them, bring
them in, and then
the needs of that
community and the ideas
and the solutions
of those people
and those communities
are naturally
going to get infused into the
environment and the products
and the services that a company
provides, because they're
the people that are
part of the company now,
and they're making these things.
So, yeah.
To think about how a company
can better address stuff,
I think it really might be
really effective to just bring
those people in to the first
point of decision making.
SPEAKER: For
everyone in the room
that's come here to see
you guys speak and share
what you do, what can we do?
What's the one concrete thing
that we can do right now,
go home and do to help
contribute to make change?
ERIK MARTINEZ: I think the first
thing that comes to my mind
is it's Pride Month.
So right now is a
great opportunity
to really get involved
in local communities.
And I'm not talking
about pink party
or whatever happens at
Civic Center or the parade.
I'm really thinking about
all those opportunities
in which especially folks of
color and queer folks of color
are telling their stories.
We're talking
about storytelling.
We're talking about information.
And all these
little local events
are happening in the Mission.
They're happening
in San Francisco.
They're happening in Oakland.
Go.
You know, patronize
those artists.
Patronize that community.
Give them your money.
Really get a sense of
what's going on with them.
Because they're telling
their stories now.
They've been telling
their stories for years,
and especially
this month they're
telling their stories now.
So really seek
those opportunities
to engage community, to
think about ways in which you
can help local artists,
local community,
and really get involved.
I mean, the time is now.
ZAKIYA HARRIS: I would
say educate yourself.
Be a lifelong student.
I'm always trying to learn more
information about everything,
pretty much.
I'm a student of history.
I think history informs
so much of the present.
I think you did a great job
of really framing that for us,
that so much of this
has just been going on.
And I think when you're informed
from a place of history,
you have more
perspective and insight
on how to address the future.
So I think education.
And I think just
starting really small
and starting with yourself.
Like, Google's
made up of people.
You're a person.
So start with yourself.
I think sometimes, again,
we're always going outside.
How can the company
do something?
Well, how can I do something?
And what am I doing every day?
And how am I making
that something
that happens during Pride
Month, but something
that's a lifestyle?
Because that's what we're
always trying to really engage
our young people on.
We're really trying to
disrupt the status quo
and get them on a new track
so they can kind of have
a different context for life.
And I think that everybody
needs to be part of that shift.
So how can we start thinking
about every single thing we
do, from the clothes
that we're wearing,
to the way that we're engaging
the people that we live in
and the communities
that we live in,
and where we're
spending our dollars,
and the groups that
we're coming to,
and the friends
that we engage with,
and the conversations that we're
having and and the [INAUDIBLE]?
Every single part of
life is an opportunity
to really be that change.
And I think that
the more we start
thinking about our
lives that way,
we then become the catalyst
for change as a collective
and as a global community.
STEPHANIE PERRON:
There's this question
that we always ask ourselves
and center our work around.
We say, how do we show
fierce love for ourselves
and for our community?
And so I think I
would maybe leave you
with that question for you
to reflect on for yourself.
And I think I would
also say that-- I mean,
I'm a person who really
believes that relationships
are at the heart of everything.
We have to connect
with one another
and build community
with one another.
So my earlier
invitation still stands
that we have a monthly
intergenerational community
dinner, potluck
style, at Our Space.
And I think if you want,
you can come and start
building community with
young people there.
Or in other places.
Everybody's doing amazing work.
[LAUGHTER]
JOCELYN WONG: All right.
Yeah, I think definitely
starting personally
is probably, I
think, the best way
if you want to take
some sort of action,
really reflecting on yourself
and your own privileges.
And you know, if you have a
certain number-- this, like,
bucket of privilege
that you have,
how do you want to use that?
And how do you want to
spend that privilege?
You can just go out and
party, have a great time,
enjoy a really nice life.
But you can sacrifice
some time or energy.
Writing a check's really great.
I'm sure any of
the organizations
wouldn't mind a check.
But there's something that can
go a lot more, which is like
if you volunteer
with youth or get
involved with an organization,
provide services.
Like even just your technical
skills that an organization
might need to pay
somebody for, and they
can't afford to pay
somebody for that position.
You come in and providing,
like, operations
or some sort of
systems admin skill,
something that you're
already doing maybe
here at your own job,
and just providing
that in another context where
maybe you're spending time
and you're not
getting paid for it.
It might be in an environment
that's not really cush.
But getting uncomfortable and
giving a little sacrifice.
Like, there's a lot of
people under oppression that
are constantly uncomfortable
and spending time that's
unnecessary on just
daily acts of living.
And if we're lucky enough
and privileged enough
to not have to be uncomfortable
in our work environment,
in society, and we're not
spending time and money just
trying to get our daily
lives done, I mean,
that's really lucky for us to
not have to deal with that.
So I think getting
uncomfortable and being
willing to make sacrifices
that some people are doing
on the regular because they have
to, that's definitely a way,
I think, to get involved more.
ZAKIYA HARRIS: I wanted
to add a little something.
Any parents in the room?
Oh my God.
You're so young.
I'm a parent too.
There's three of us.
That's awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
But you know, aunties,
uncles in the room?
OK, yeah.
Nieces and nephews.
Hopefully you're connected
to some young people,
whether they identify
as queer or not.
I think to some extent,
we're getting older,
we've got work to do as adults.
But sometimes I
look at the adults
and I'm just kind of
like, all is lost.
Let's focus on the
young-- I'm joking.
I'm joking.
But you know, let's really
focus on the young people.
I think we forget
that sometimes,
that we have young
people in our families,
in our lives that
we're around, and we
have to make sure
that we're really
training them and educating
them to be the type of adults
that we want to have to
really be global citizens.
And I don't say that lightly.
I mean, there's young
people who don't even
know how to speak to someone
when they walk into the room.
Or do they know how to
acknowledge difference?
Do they understand
the same conversations
that we're having?
Like, how can we
really also work
with young people who
are really the future?
Because they're the
ones that are building.
And They're not even the future.
They're the now, right?
They're the ones
that are really going
to be inheriting all these
problems on the planet.
And so we have to make
sure that we're really
empowering the next
generation of young people
who maybe don't have
all these barriers to be
able to be at the
table with folks that
do have the barriers,
because that's
kind of where the
work really-- where
the rubber meets the road.
I think there's a
lot of work that we
need to do in that arena.
San Francisco has less children
than any other major city
in America.
It has the smallest
population of children.
It also has the greatest
disparity economically.
So some of the richest
children in America
live in San Francisco, and
some of the poorest children
live in San Francisco.
And the majority of the
folks that are maybe
on the lower side of
the economic spectrum
are folks of color.
There's also more dogs
here than children,
which is very interesting.
But I mean, that also speaks
a lot to the culture, right?
So I mean, again, how are we
really empowering young people
and really making sure
that they are trained up
to navigate this world?
PABLO RODRIGUEZ:
I have two dogs.
[LAUGHTER]
So again, I agree
with everything
that was said before.
So I think that it should
start from the inside,
so you're starting
with yourself.
But I just want to share this.
I'm not going to say names,
but I was hanging out
with one of my friends
on 24th Street,
and she said, oh,
one of my friends
is coming over just
to hang with us too.
And I was like, oh, fine.
Great.
Cool.
Whatever.
But before the friend
came with us, I asked her,
so is she white?
And she said, yes.
And I was like, is she new?
And she was like, yeah.
She's been living
here for two months.
And I'm like, OK.
We meet, and I was
carrying some feathers.
And she says, what is that?
And I said, oh, you know,
I'm [INAUDIBLE] dancer.
And she says, wait.
What is that?
And I'm like, uh,
well, I'm usually
dancing at 24 and Mission.
And then I ask her,
where do you live?
And she says, 24 and Mission.
And I'm like-- can
I drop the mic?
[LAUGHTER]
She says, 24 and Mission.
And I looked at
her and I said, oh.
Interesting.
So engage.
I just want to say that.
Like, 24 and Mission
and she hasn't even
seen the fact that I've been
there dancing for a long time.
And it's just crazy.
So when you stand
anywhere you are,
try to acknowledge yourselves.
Try to acknowledge the
people that are around you.
Even if you don't know them.
You don't have to say hi.
You don't even have to smile.
If you're one of those
persons that walk really fast,
try to walk slower.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Thank you so
much, everyone, for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Just my last words.
Your work is life changing,
and in a lot of ways,
it's life saving.
And I don't exaggerate there.
So really, to be on
the ground, working
with all of these youth
in desperate situations
and youth that are
seeing them thrive
and seeing them come
through that, it's amazing.
And every day is hard.
So thank you.
Thanks again.
So one more round
of applause, please.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]